ich mache jetzt war musik an mal gucken
ob die darauf reagiert ich glaube nicht
dass werth das wird brutal so wir haben
die handys jetzt eben genau der gleichen
position und ich kann von dieser
position auch nur 13 moment noch um
einen kurzen augenblick geduld und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen bio
laden knäckebrot gegessen sind
politischen seite ich hoffe natürlich
geht es gut
heute geht es um die genialsten iphone
gadgets die ich gefunden habe
oder halt auch auf anderen seiten muss
ich sagen ein paar kommen auch von
anderen seite und wir haben eine menge
ein paar sachen fehlen leider noch
aufgrund des chorus und so weiter gibt
es enorme lieferverzögerung auch für
mich das ist sehr schade
trotzdem sage euch hier erst mal den
ganzen produkte nicht bestellt und dann
sehen wir uns jetzt sofort hier wieder
okay leute was geht herzlich willkommen
auch von dieser position
wir starten direkt mal und zwar habe ich
bestellt dieses fdp ist charger das fdg
ja keine ahnung was das genau heißen
soll auf jeden fall ist es ein gerät
womit man alles gleichzeitig aufladen
kann also iphone airports smart watch
apple penn und wird weiß ich noch was
muss ich beim ausparken bin ich sehr
gespannt drauf fast schon mein lieblings
produkt als nächstes haben wir dieses
dingen hier ist ähnlich wie ein pop
socket weiß ich jetzt nicht was ich von
halten soll habe ich einfach mal
mitgenommen weil ich es war auffällig so
was ich auch noch bestellt habe da bin
ich sehr gespannt darauf ist diese
iphone mini disco das sieht ja brutal
aus hier auf diesen fotos als wird das
wirklich heftige lights perform sag ich
mal
deswegen das kann man einfach ans iphone
dran stecken unten und dann funktioniert
das hoffentlich vielleicht sogar zur
musik kommt man sieht schon extrem lies
aus dann habe ich noch bestellt das ist
schon so lange her deswegen zeige ich
euch das hier so eine anti spyware
das heißt wenn ihr jetzt neben einem
sitzt der kann auch nicht auf euer handy
schauen wenn ihr diese hülle drauf habt
so soll das eigentlich funktionieren
deswegen das hat ja auch mitgenommen
schauen wir uns auch gleich an mini
power bank habe ich
die ja die habe ich für dieses video
bestellt weil die guck mal leute gebt
euch mal dieses dieses foto luhr wie
klein das aussieht ja so eine ganz menge
power bringen dies auch da bin ich mal
gespannt ob die wirklich so ist dann
haben wir hier noch ein leid case
sozusagen für iphone 11 pro ist glaube
ich auch da keine ahnung ob ich euch
jetzt schon alles gezeigt habe ich weiß
nicht was da noch so angekommen ist auf
jeden fall haben wir erst mal genug das
schauen wir uns jetzt an viel spaß
ok herzlich willkommen zurück ja also
ich muss vielleicht erst mal noch zu
sagen wir haben viele sachen haben wir
insgesamt auf jeden fall so sechs sieben
verschiedene produkte ich habe auf jeden
fall das iphone lv gadgets gesund
einfach weiß das neueste ist und alles
was hinunter so angeht ich habe gerade
von 11% wird wollte ich mir der mensch
das aber überholen
alles was heute und so angeht wie extrem
wir haben eine leiste hülle oder sondern
so eine folie alter dies ganz krass das
habe ich dann halt gemeinde bestellt
damit passt es gibt allerdings auch
alles für alle iphones so ich habe jetzt
wahrscheinlich im titel iphone 11 gehen
weil es das neueste und mehr dann leute
das für interessieren so hat jetzt das
nicht auch dann für android alle
zusammen so ein hinweis um so was das
weiß ich nicht so auswählen
doch das ist so nice das werde ich mir
safe da hinstellen okay dann würde ich
sagen ihr habt ja alle produkte schauen
wir sehen wir von direct erstmalig will
mit diesem anfang war ich das schon so
sollte das lied schon so ewig eigentlich
sollte es gar nicht in diesem part rein
ich wollte aber jetzt mit reinen weil
sonst findet ihr braucht mir okay und
zwar haben wir hier eine kaputt
wahrscheinlich hat keiner von euch eine
ahnung was das ist okay ich hab ich eben
schon gezeigt das ist einfach ich weiß
nicht wofür man es brauche ich weiß aber
brutal eine iphone discokugeln ich bin
mal gespannt ob die musik reagiert er
auf festivals oder so ist halt folge ist
ein richtiger magnet ok also schenken
wir das ganze mal ab
und jetzt meinte die reagiert auf musik
und essen alter kümmern das ist noch mal
das licht aus
daher macht es auch noch andere jasid
schon 2001 sitzt der studie nicht so
also ist schon nice ich würde jetzt war
ich würde sagen wir die kraft das ist
nur dass das kann ich ja einfach für
jede party nehmen und das ist einfach so
eine kleine kugel
ich mache jetzt mal musik an mal gucken
ob die darauf reagiert ich glaube nicht
dass wäre das wäre ein bild für götter
meine fraktion rhythmus
bist du dir sicher aber ist schon nach
zwei wochen erst mal das licht lernen
wobei ist schlank hat es nicht mehr
es könnte schon sein dass ich finde das
fahrzeug auf musik reagiert machen wir
jetzt noch mal an
weil jetzt ist cool ich glaube schon
dass es auch musik reagiert also das ist
so genial reger das behalte ich selbst
damit bin ich der absolute king auf
jeder party leute das kann ich euch
sowas von empfehlen bisschen wird mein
verteilt machen wir mal reicher oder was
haben wir noch eine gute frage
okay ich bin dafür dass wir hier mit
weiter machen das ist das ist ein twingo
eines tages hoffe ich eine mail bekommen
dass auch gibt dir das mal ich finde
allein das schon
das sieht doch super wenn ein deutscher
youtuber dieses gerät braucht dann wohl
nur ich ja ich habe so viele airports
ich habe jetzt auch eine paypal watch
dann habe ich natürlich auch ein handy
und da kannst halt alles gleichzeitig
mit laden sogar noch so ein stifter den
habe ich nicht
er kidnappt ok ich muss sagen ich hab
mir das ganze ein bisschen größer
vorgestellt tatsächlich aber gut heißt
ja nix da hatte man das braucht man halt
zusammen macht das burg das baut man
noch zusammen und dann ist es
wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen größer
ja sogar mit mit einem lightning kabel
hier ich habe das in weiß bestellt weil
ich weiß eigentlich als habe mal schöner
finden als schwarz okay kann man auf
jeden fall mit dabei
die stylisch aus ich weiß nicht mal wie
teuer ist wahr aber ich euch ja auch dem
gezeigt will connecten das jetzt erst
mal hier
ok jetzt blind ist kann man ja sehen
okay jetzt haben wir hier einmal die
fapl watch aus dem leisten part zu der
vielleicht noch einen ausschalten
batterie schwach egal
dafür braucht man es jetzt sogar
vielleicht noch ein einzelnes video und
dann kommt
durch die mit einer originalen apple vox
vergleiche weil das wirklich bis jetzt
ich habe es schon so im kopf gehabt das
ist vielleicht das beste spruch was wir
bestellt haben könnte sein und hier
haben wir die airports die clever schon
mal hier unten
ok hier ist dieses dingen ist
wahrscheinlich perfekt hierfür gemacht
weiß nur nicht ob dieses ding wireless
charging hat werden wir gleich erfahren
da ist auf jeden fall die batterie
schwach kann ich einmal dann trainiere
so und im optimalen fall
das lädt sollte jetzt alles laden also
die akkus laden auf jeden fall
ich glaube diese fapl watch hat keine
stars integriert leider deswegen noch
nicht so sicher eigentlich sollte das
hat irgendwo ein anschlags zum
anschließen laden ja ok wahrscheinlich
hat es ist nicht egal wie demonstrieren
dass sie nur ich muss sagen extrem
leichtes teil
sowas ist perfekt vor allem für die
leute die die ganzen sachen besitzen wir
damit kompatibel sind kann ich das nur
empfehlen
ich werde auf jeden fall selber behalten
die meisten anderen sachen verlose ich
habe wie immer auf instagram 30 alex wie
in meiner story dann okay wir machen
weiter und kommen zum nächsten produkt
und radial eigentlich und zwar wer kennt
es nicht man fährt bahn und drückt auf
dein handy und neben ihr sitzt und opi
oder so und er guckt auch niemand will
auf dem handy oder irgendwer platz hat
ich bitte euch jemand das turnier in new
york gemacht ja das war so verrückt sein
kleine politik passt es gesehen dass wir
auch das buch geguckt hat das bleibe ich
euch immer einhalten
dieses ding in passt perfekt für solche
momente an zwar haben wir hier eine anti
spyware die ich jetzt für mein handy
bestellt habe gibt es allerdings für
alle handys ist ja logisch und ja ich
würde sagen wir checken jetzt mal ab ist
an sich sogar ziemlich professionell
eingepackt ich weiß gar nicht mehr wie
teuer war
die hat auch qualität auf jeden fall so
jetzt mache ich mal das war sehr gut
und jetzt kann ich die hier auf mein
iphone kleben
ok ich weiß nicht ob das jetzt so
perfekt war
es könnt ihr hier einmal dieses geniale
hintergrundbild beobachten ja wie ich
auch wenn ich so drauf gucke passt auch
jetzt drehe ich das allerdings ein
bisschen für euch und kann man es immer
noch sehen und jetzt jetzt nicht mehr so
wir haben die handys jetzt genau der
gleichen position und ich kann von
dieser position auch 19
also ist schon an sich ein hilfreiches
dingen
ich weiß nicht ob man das unbedingt
braucht aber ich behalte es ist auf
jeden fall mehr richtig neiße erfindung
das muss man sagen die anti spyware für
jedes einfach genial
okay machen weiter also ich muss sagen
worüber das jetzt die produkte sind
schon heiß oder bis jetzt eigentlich
kein scheiß ja sonst haben wir
eigentlich immer scheiß dabei die frage
ist nur was kommt noch
das ist dass das hier ist ein download
schild für meinen youtube-kanal leute
ihr müsst alle erzählen dicken daumen
nach oben gehen ganz ganz wichtig hier
kann man jetzt glaube ich dein handy
dafür ist das gedacht auf jeden fall die
ihm das dazu ist ein wiesenbord kopf
doppelt sein handy einfach so hin zu
stellen
man guckt dann kann man damit arbeiten
dafür nicht eigentlich popsongs besser
muss ich sagen irgendwie ein bisschen
ein bisschen laut will ich es in müll
schmeißen also ich glaube das wäre ich
nicht erfolg hat man kann es mal
behalten ich weiß nicht ob jetzt auf den
ersten blick würde ich sagen feiere ich
nicht so krass vielleicht kann man es
mal gebraucht ich weiß dass ich leute
ihr könnt ja sehr gern mal eure meinung
dazu in die kommentare schreiben wir
machen schnell weiter mit dem nächsten
gadget und das ist diese discokugel
kannst du wirst jetzt am besten die das
gucken oder hier ist gut gefühlt habe
und dann kommt das und dann kommen die
antes bei dingens und das hier ist am
schlechtesten
okay okay das ist falsch platziert das
könnte man noch zu den größten airport
des cases aus aller welt packen wovon es
sicherlich auch noch eine fahrt gehen
wird wollte da solltet ihr aber auch den
letzten part auf jeden fall abschrecken
wer dazu online gekommen ist okay als
nächstes haben wir hier in mainz gleich
aufgestellt zu haben
ich meine ich habe die bestellt weil die
mir als kleinste powering der welt oder
so angezeigt wurde
ist es aber nicht oder ich habe eine
kleine runde schafft es dann extrem mini
power bank oder so ja hab ich jetzt halt
mit power bringt aber irgendwie selbst
erklärt dass die jetzt nicht besonders
was aber hier 74 prozent geladen
naja es gibt schlimmeres ich muss sagen
ich behalte die weil ich habe keine
eigene bank trotzdem finde ich das
produkt jetzt auch nicht so machen ich
glaube die meisten haben wir fast schon
das liegt auch daran weil zwei sachen
die fand ich auch noch übelst cool
die sind da ja nicht da und ich wollte
eigentlich mal als meister mit videos
machen das wäre doch ein bisschen
größere sachen gewesen dass hier habe
ich auch noch bestellt das ist auch so
ein bisschen älter und weiß dass ein
waterproof speaker dass die frage ist ob
man im wasser tun kann wenn der
nordhalbkugel ist einfach schon mal
leute das hier vielleicht noch ganz kurz
zum schluss das ist eine dusch box war
kann man unter der jungs hier ganz
entspannt dran gruppen habe ich auch
gefunden nachdem ich im iphone 11 chips
gesucht habe deswegen könnte man auch
unter musik passen wir testen das war
noch kurz
schon beim gleichen gibt die weiter
unten in die ecke da das st
[Musik]
jetzt machen wir was da drauf beendeten
in der
es sind leute eigentlich was geschichten
aus scheint da hat er ja für mich
zumindest funktioniert aber ich liebe
diesen song jetzt nicht mehr auf trends
platz eins corona hier hatte soviel dazu
lasst dann nach ungarn abonniert den
kanal wenn ihr sagt mache auf jeden fall
noch nicht wenn er sagt macht wird er
noch ein paar dazu dann schreibt das
geld in die kommentare wo war ich
eigentlich jedes gadget was ich cool
fand und bestellt habe also bessere gibt
es gerade nicht auf dem markt die man
sowas verwenden könnte aber hier noch
ein zweiter kanal alex v ist in der
bildung vor link dort gibt es jeden tag
um 13 30 ein video
wir sehen uns dann hier im laufe der
woche wieder ich möchte ihn jetzt immer
nur solange qualitative videos bringen
und nicht mal so irgendwie also
ausschließlich nur noch so coole sachen
wie das hier damit bin ich voll
zufrieden und ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen
wir sehen uns dabei das macht jetzt
immer
[Musik]